I love comedy, I love women, so without further ado,
Annaleigh Ashford ladies and gentlemen.
(applause)
Hi.
Oh I am such a fan, I can't believe I'm here.
I mean on a Zoom with you.
I was freaking out about,
I watched the pilot of your show.
I was like, yeah, that's what you do with an opportunity.
Oh, that is the sweetest.
You know, funny ladies like this usually are messy,
and wild, and you know she's the kind of girl who will do
shots with you all night
and then ask you if you want her kidney.
So she's that kind of girl.
So I really, I got the luckiest girl in the land to play.
She's wild and fierce and strong
and that's the kind of girls we all wanna play.
Are you wild and messy in your real life,
or are you able to channel it for her?
You know, I weirdly have kept my wild side
to the stage and the wildest that I got,
this is so crazy.
I was a go go dancer in college.
Yes, for glam rock parties.
But not like, like oh, I did for like 70s glam rock parties
with like top hats and sequins and,
and really high go go boots.
So that was about as close as it gets.
But I was very clean and boring.
I was really focused on the dancing.
See that in a weird way doesn't surprise me
because I'm wild and messy and I'm not kidding.
I'm not really that great at playing it.
Like one of the hardest things I think any comedian
would say is like doing a drunk scene is like,
it's so hard.
The hardest.
It's like very very hard to navigate a subtle slur.
Because when you're drunk you don't think you're that drunk.
So that's the, that's the hard part.
It's a trick.
I know.
And I saw like your messy wildness
and I just loved the pilot.
First of all, you cannot have humor without heart.
I love a good fart joke, do not get me wrong.
But, it's like there's a difference.
And I love when funny is true to life.
And we can have heart.
I mean you've worked with so many amazing comedians,
ala John Mulaney, the comedians' comedian.
What was it like to work with him?
I would say that if John was here
he would also say like you and I he loves a fart joke.
(laughter)
You know, I mean let's just get real.
Yeah.
Working with John, it was the best.
He is so bright and light and funny
and he is also, all of his comedy is based in honesty
and what's happening in the world right now.
'Cause that's what makes it funny
and I mean he's, he's a genius person.
Let's just get real.
I just think the show really goes for it.
It's so fun, you are taking an opportunity
and making it so much more.
And I could tell that from the commercials
and then seeing the pilot I was like,
I mean you're just chewing up the scenery.
And I'm really excited to be cheering you on
and also if anybody like doesn't already check out
all your Instagrams you do really cool things with your son.
Which is so fun and playful
and maybe all of that go go dancing
and costuming was all prep, you know for him?
Amen.
Now your son is in like really fun costumes.
Yeah, and I don't even make him.
It's just the outfit he picks out for the day.
And I'm like ooh, yes, you better work, live those dreams.
Perfect.
Oh Annaleigh Ashford, thank you so much for coming
on the show.
B Positive airs Thursdays at 8:30, 7:30 central on CBS.
It's gonna be huge.
(upbeat music)